everyone welcome to the state of media
playback we'll be talking today about
how to do media playback the right way
so things have changed quite a bit over
time from the earliest Android days to
now but we've come up with a pretty good
solution on a lot of these things you
actually do need to do to really get the
best experience out of media playback
and we'll be talking through a lot of
the best practices around all of that a
little bit about me I've been doing
Android development for about five years
now started doing it in my spare time
and then moved to doing it full-time
first at fun where and then at Facebook
and now I work at Google as a developer
advocate so I'm working on both the
advanced Android Udacity course which is
online learning to get your learn on as
well as a new android development
patterns series of kind of going into
all of these best practices my focus has
primarily been on the framework and the
support library and actually worked
really closely with the media framework
team as well to write a lot of these
things I'm going to be talking about now
media playback can mean a lot to a lot
of different people so today we're going
to be focusing on just one part of that
specifically audio playback believe me
there's enough in the land of media that
we could cover a whole presentation a
whole conference about it but for this
will be focusing solely on audio
playback for video you might consider
looking at the cast companion library
it's up on github it's actually a really
good example of a lot of the best
practices around video playback
especially with interacting with Google
cast devices so when we talk about any
app right we really want to start with
the user right they are the most
important part of the app it's really
our job as developers to give them the
best experience that we can and that
really starts with what they're
expecting from your app right that
starts with the description and
screenshots and
into the actual functionality of the app
and what we're trying to do is rather
than just meet those expectations we're
really trying to exceed those
expectations right the worst thing that
we can do to users is have them expect
that oh this is supposed to do this but
then all of a sudden your app unlike
every other app doesn't do it the right
way and for media apps especially for
audio playback there are a lot of things
that do come as kind of preconditions
and expectations from the user and you
know of course for audio apps the first
user expectation is really background
playback or if you've ever had a media
app that like you hit the home button it
just stops playing right even for video
apps like YouTube for example now they
also support kind of that background
playback so for audio apps particularly
this is kind of one of those base
requirements and when we think about
background playback where you should
really already be thinking about
services right these are the top level
Android component specifically for doing
work in the background that isn't tied
to an activity or short live broadcast
receiver so it really is kind of the
natural choice for handling all of our
media state so what actually goes into
media playback at just kind of the
10,000 foot level a lot of this comes
down to kind of this super simplified
version of kind of the events in media
playback so for every service right
that's running eventually it's going to
be created right this may be the start
of playback or when your app first gets
created but we have some one-time
initialization in the created step and
then eventually when the put when the
user actually hits that play button
that's we're going to we're going to go
into the playing state playing state
here really means any time when we are
actually outputting audio right so this
is slightly different from the pause
state which would be the reverse of any
time that we're ready to play or getting
ready to play but not actually playing
any music
so from a play/pause perspective
obviously for any audio app we're going
to want to be able to transition back
and forth between those states but at
some point the user is probably going to
stop playback this may be something like
swiping away the notification or closing
your app or rebooting their device or
what have you in that case we're going
to move to the stopped state in this
case is really the case where we're
explicitly closed and we can generally
remove all of our information and say
hey we're done playing back and where we
were going to then transition to the
destroyed state which is where we do
kind of that one time cleanup state of
releasing system resources stopping our
service that type of thing there may be
some difference between stopped and
destroyed and we'll get into that so it
wouldn't be much of an audio app if it
didn't actually play audio that's kind
of a big part of it so will be assuming
that you're using something like media
player which is built into android but
the same talk works actually extremely
well if you're using something like
exoplayer or any other third-party
playback system all this is kind of
agnostic to that and really kind of
building on top of that to say like okay
well beyond just let's play some audio
can we do a little bit more but for
media player we can see it has a pretty
easy straightforward flow for our
different event states right you're
created will create a new media player
and then of course will prepare and play
when we go to playing will pause pause
we stop when we stop right this should
be fairly straightforward from a media
playback perspective and well we're done
it media plays pause and we have lots of
time back for getting ready for lunch
but maybe we should go into a little bit
more detail so we're really trying to do
it the right way right in fact just
playing audio in the background with no
controls no information no idea of what
the users doing is probably actually net
negative for the user and we want to get
on to the
positive side so what can we get to
really kind of bump this up to at least
an acceptable experience rather than
something that is just blasting music
from your phone with no controls in the
background that they can't control and
have to find your app to kill it
probably not the best place to be so the
first thing we want to do is audio focus
now is really is one of those keys of
being a great citizen on Android so it's
the way of getting kind of that heads up
to other apps and to the system that you
want to play something right that you
are ready to play and at the same point
it also means that someone can't
necessarily take your audio focus right
what we don't want is we don't want
multiple apps playing back on top of one
another and causing issues where you
can't understand either one of them now
this is slightly distinct from actually
playing audio it's the intent to play
audio so we want to continue to have
audio focus anytime we're ready to play
or going to play or really taking on
that role of the main media playback in
a nap so we can look at some code like
this to request audio focus will use
audio manager for this and then actually
going through and requesting audio focus
right in this case looking for the
stream music right the main playback
stream for audio playback and hoping to
gain audio focus now one thing to note
is that almost all the time you'll be
granted audio focus but there are a few
exceptions where you'll actually not be
granted audio focus one example is maybe
when the users in a phone call and that
probably isn't the time to start
blasting music because they're actually
talking with another human which is
great but it means that our media
playback should probably just work and
say you know what like we didn't get
audio focus so we shouldn't continue but
most of the time you'll be able to
proceed and play your glorious music but
then of course we need to abandon audio
focus when we're stopping playback right
when we get to that final stopped state
what is that audio focus change listener
thing I just put it in here for no
reason well it's actually how you learn
from other apps what's going on in the
system right it's your link to other
apps and to the system saying like well
someone else is requesting audio focus
and how does your app actually react to
that it's the callback system so you may
be getting an audio focus loss now this
is pretty serious this means that the
other app is taking over permanent
control of audio focus at least while
it's the first the last one to regress
it and your audio focus isn't coming
back you're done it's not your turn yet
so in this case will want to move to the
stopped state right your kind of done
playing back audio they've moved on to a
different app now one thing to consider
is that maybe you don't want to
immediately remove notifications and
delete your service and everything
immediately upon audio loss you could
decide to wait around for 30 seconds
just in case they like accidentally hit
the wrong app but this is really kind of
one of those user experience things
where you should test with your users on
what they expect when they accidentally
hit another app for most google apps
when they do lose audio focus you'll see
that they immediately stop playback and
awaits you know any future concerns now
there's another one called loss
transient now in this case it's not a
permanent loss it's just a short-term
loss so this may be a case where you're
using something like Google Maps and
it's announcing like oh you're going to
be on time right a temporary loss but
you can expect it back so in this case
loss transient means you should just
pause your media playback now there's
the other one you may be very familiar
with which is the loss transient can
duck now this is the basic when like a
notification sound comes in right and in
this case the expectation is that you're
going to lower the volume you don't
necessarily need to pause completely but
you just lower the volume so that the
other sound can be heard clearly and
then you'll regain audio focus with
audio game
now one thing to keep in mind with the
can duck is that you don't have to lower
your volume you can actually pause like
for example if you're a podcast playing
app and you having spoken words it's
very important that the user hears
everything that's going on and maybe
they don't want google maps talking over
them you can actually pause for any of
these events right and then resume when
you get audio gain so there aren't
necessarily requirements to do anything
but in any case you should be respecting
these audio focus changes so what is our
updated life cycle so we can see here
now we're requesting focus when we start
playback and we're removing focus
abandoning focus when we actually
stopped now don't this isn't tied to
playing audio or back and you know even
with just this we already are a lot
better citizen and working well with the
system and other media apps but are we
done done no all right so more more to
go and that's fine because these are
important things that users are going to
expect now one of the things and
probably my favorite named broadcast is
the becoming noisy broadcast which is
kind of exactly how it sounds it's
actually when you're listening to
something on headphones or a Bluetooth
headset and the bluetooth headset runs
out of batteries or the headphone gets
yanked out and all of a sudden it's
blaring to the whole crowd to the whole
audience of wow that's really what
you're listening to right now probably
should have used becoming noisy to be
able to pause your playback so it's a
really nice way of saying like okay well
the user is expecting that there are not
blaring out their music to everyone and
we can register a becoming noisy
broadcast very simply with register
receiver and then of course
unregistering now in this case because
this is tied to not wanting to blare
music out to the world these events are
going to be tied
into the actual playing and pause state
so only when we're outputting audio are
we going to want to register for the
becoming noisy and then unregister when
we actually pause playback so slightly
different here and actually at this
point we're in a fairly decent state
we're never going to be playing audio
when user is not expecting it and we're
going to play well with other apps that
are doing notification to other things
but we're not quite to the best media
playback experience in fact we haven't
talked about controls at all and it's
certainly one of those very frustrating
things when you're trying to find the
pause button or the play button or the
next track button because that track
isn't appropriate for everyone who's in
the car and you want that control a bit
available as many places as possible you
don't want have to dive into a nap and
find it in your reasons or what have you
so thankfully Android offers a lot of
ways to actually get controls everywhere
and one of the ones that's most
frustrating at work are headphones and
bluetooth controls the times when you're
really listening music and you don't
necessarily want to pull off your phone
and they have buttons on them now so we
should probably get those working and
collectively these are called media
buttons in fact they're just like any
other button that has hit on the system
there are key events that are sent to
the system and on to your apps and by
default the system is actually going to
capture all of these and then send them
out as a media button broadcast which of
course your app can then receive and
handle and you can build just a simple
broadcast receiver that then extracts a
key event and then does work on it and
we found that basically all of these
receivers were doing the exact same
thing right they need to look at a key
event and then extract from the intent
what the key event was and then somehow
transfer that chart service so we built
it all for you we built a Media button
receiver in the support library version
23.1 and higher so that it kind of
handles a lot of the boilerplate for you
how does it work you have no
whatsoever it's just a few manifests
entries you'll add it to your manifest
you'll note our media button
intent-filter here and then instead of
writing all the code yourself what it's
going to do is it's going to look for a
service that's also in your manifest
that has that same media button intent
and what it will do is every time the
broadcast receiver receives a media
button intent it'll forward that on to
your service which makes it really nice
because in your service that has your
media player and that type of things you
can actually act on those events the big
problem we found was that in so many
times you'd want the broadcast receiver
to see oh you hit the play/pause
play/pause button where you hit the next
track button now all the sudden just
somehow get that to my service and this
really helps in that common case so one
problem though if you add this code it
won't actually work thanks Ian but it
turns out that this is an important
thing for all of Android and that
there's what's called a preferred media
button receiver in fact it's probably
not a very good idea if every media app
on your phone all received every media
button first we'd have many many
processes starting all at the same time
as well as of course there's usually
only one app that has audio focus that
wants to play back apps that is actually
the one that is the preferred app so
it's very similar to audio focus in that
it's a last wins kind of model right if
you're the last one to say I want to be
the preferred Media button receiver then
you'll become the preferred Media button
receiver so if you've ever had like play
music take over when you hit the
play/pause button or when you get into
your car that's usually the app you were
expecting not actually handling being
the preferred Media button receiver so
if all apps do this correctly then when
you do get in your car and your
Bluetooth auto connects and it starts
playback it's actually going to start
the app that you actually last used
rather than the one that was just last
registered so and that's really where
media session compat another class comes
in it's really that consolidated
connection
in between your app and the system and
it's actually doing a lot more than you
might imagine so we built the media
session api's in lollipop and media
session combat brings that back to every
app even down to v4 if you're that
person who's still supporting v4 please
novi force right VA maybe everything
cool at media starts at about v8 so
we're covering everyone with media
session compat and it's actually doing
just about everything for you with just
a simple few methods but of course we do
want to create it and there's one thing
you want to do especially is make sure
you setting flags you want to set the
both media buttons and the transport
controls flag this is what actually
allows some of those connections to to
your app now if you're doing like a very
temporary thing like say showing an
advertisement that probably shouldn't
have these actions those flags are
actually a really good way of turning
those off temporarily and then turning
them back on but for the most guard this
is for media playback you'll want to
just always set those two flags and then
we have this concept of callbacks and
these callbacks are really the on play
on pause basically all of the events
that your app wants to respond to and
we'll use our callbacks floor is kind of
the main way of interacting with media
player so everything that's coming into
your service everything that's coming
into your app then goes through one of
these callbacks to actually then trigger
the media player the nice part about
this solution is that it works really
well if you do want to enable cast in
your media app because you can just
switch out your callbacks and switch
from local callbacks to remote callbacks
and not have to actually touch any of
the rest of your code just have on play
and on pause do a different thing based
on whatever the current callback is so
the one thing we actually need to really
do then to become the preferred media
button playback is called set active
and we'll set active to true basically
at the same time we're requesting audio
focus and we've been granted audio focus
and then set active to false when we
actually stopped so this is kind of the
important part that's actually going to
get us to the preferred Media button
receiver and you'll note that once we
call these lines then magically all of
our broadcast receivers start working
this is also the exact time where we can
use Media button receivers other handy
method which is handle intent so this
handle intent takes in your media
session compat extracts the key events
and then hands it off to your call backs
all without having to write any more
code it's just one line in your on start
command and all of a sudden your call
backs are then receiving media button
events without you having to write or
decode key events to get through all
that now there's one wrinkle though
because how does it know that when you
hit the play/pause button on your
bluetooth remote that you want to play
or you want to pause right we haven't
actually told you what's going on we
haven't told the system anything so
that's what playback state compat is for
it's actually how you tell the system
what's currently going on and there's
actually two parts to it one is set
state so this is what's currently going
on this is like state playing state
paused buffering as well as kind of your
position so if you're 30 seconds into a
track you'll set the position to 30 the
other part is set actions now set
actions are what controls we support so
you'll definitely want to support site
play pause and stop but of course if you
support skip to next or not those
actions are actually going to be really
important to set here if you don't set
those actions here you won't get media
buttons for them and you won't get
controls on Android wear and on Android
auto as well they all rely on kind of
those actions to be set so if you want
to support rewind again one of the
actions you need to add so these are
kind of actually grouped together
as many times they change at the same
time right if you are buffering you
probably don't have a fast forward
button if you're paused you probably
don't have a pause button right you want
to switch the actions at the same time
you're switching your state what about
those cool lock screen controls we added
them in ice cream sandwich and you could
play pause without unlocking your phone
it's probably the coolest thing like
except for the whole combining phones
and tablets together but that's not
important for this talk and it's
actually pretty easy there requires a
little bit of metadata in fact a picture
right would kind of be required for this
information now this is actually used
for a lot more than just lock screen
controls like Android wear will take the
background image from your metadata so
what kinds of metadata well there's
actually like 27 different kinds of
metadata you can add these are kind of
the most important ones the ones you'd
expect title album artist album artist
that's a different thing as well as the
duration right that goes really well
with that position we added in playback
state as well as the actual images
themselves you can store them as bitmaps
or provide your eyes to content your
eyes which then the app can read now
really really don't store like 4,000 x
4000 pixel bitmaps in this these are
sent to other apps so if you're doing it
you probably want to set a smaller image
in a bitmap and then provide a URI for a
full-size image in case apps really do
want that level of information so how
does this actually work with our
playback with our life cycle well we'll
want to create set flags that call back
in oncreate and then set active make
sure our metadata and state are updated
when we start playing and then of course
when we pause one update our state
stopped will set active to false right
similarly again along with our audio
focus and then we'll release when we're
all done so
screen controls like how old are those
right we actually removed all of them so
in fact notifications are the new
hotness for the lock screen and in fact
we probably should have been using
notifications all along they're kind of
a big deal doesn't really make sense to
lock your phone just to get to media
controls so having notifications
actually turns out to be really useful
but writing a custom notification that
does media controls and have it work
well on every device it's actually
really hard so we built it for you we
backported kind of the media style
notification which was added in lollipop
so that now you can use it on all
platform burdens but that did come with
a few caveats first of all prior to API
14 you couldn't actually have buttons in
your notification it's just one click
target and can you imagine like must
have been horrible but we've moved on
but thankfully media style will just
continue to work it'll give you the best
effort it can at that level on API 14 we
actually can add actions so you'll note
there can be up to three actions in the
collapsed view that single line view of
the notification API 16 jellybean added
expanded notifications where now we can
have up to five actions and on 5 panel
and higher we'll just use the framework
media style so as we change things and
things get even better or the styling
changes you'll always be know that you
are in sync with the framework at all
api 20 and 1 and higher so i don't like
writing boilerplate i'm sure many of you
love writing boilerplate right
boilerplate no wow you all hate what i
play too so it's ok i wrote it for you
because i want you guys to save as much
time as possible and so i built this
helper that actually takes a media
session compact and builds a
notification for you and it all relies
on media metadata is get description so
get description actually looks at all of
those metadata fields that you've added
and
extracts just the most important
information from it it turns out that it
extracts the same information the same
fields that I already talked about it's
like I planned it that way but there's
actually display specific metadata items
if you want to specifically override
this case because this is actually what
Android wear is also going to use but
once we have that description we can
actually build most of our notification
directly from that description getting
the title the text and any subtext
that's available as well as a large icon
in the actual icon itself we can also
actually fill out other things like the
cliq intent for going through as long as
we call set session activity on our
media session comp at we can then pull
it out for our notification additionally
in lollipop there's a concept of hidden
notifications right you may not want all
of your notifications on the lock screen
all the time when so for these
notifications for media controls you
probably want to set them to public that
way people can interact even if they've
chosen to hide their other notifications
and then of course when the
notifications actually removed slapped
away will want to stop playback right we
don't necessarily want the user to
continue to hear music when they
specifically swiped away our
notification so you'll note we actually
use a different one called get action
intent and that's actually fairly easy
it's basically me faking what you'd
receive as a media button building our
own key intent and then building a
broadcast that's just going to trigger
that same media button receiver going to
your service going to your callback so
again you don't need to write anything
more of all this so I actually have a
gist available of all this code so I'm
sure you're furiously writing there must
be someone for yours right no I'm just
working on your laptops it's fine it's
fine I understand so let's actually
build our notification you'll still need
a small icon for the status bar and
there's one thing that's slightly
different about media style
notifications in that the color
rather than just affecting the small
icon it's going to fill the whole
background of the image so bright orange
not a good idea generally you want to
use something branded for your color the
primary dark is actually a really good
example of something to use but you
could also use a more neutral color by
default it will default to a gray color
so it wouldn't be much of a media
notification if it didn't have any
actions so I'd say a play/pause action
and then actually use our get action
intent to help us build the pending
intent that we need and then we'll
actually call creating a media style so
this media style actually requires that
we then choose which actions zero
indexed you want to display in that
compact view that single line view in
this case will show our play pause
button right because that's kind of
useful right but you may want to show
say a next track button is a really good
example of something you may also want
to show in the compact view and then we
want to set the media session so this
session token' it's actually really
critical to get things like Android
we're working so Android wear is
actually going to use that session token
to pass callbacks to you on android 5.1
higher devices so if you forget this
line you get a great notification that
appears on your wrist and you'll hit the
play/pause button and it won't do
anything and your users will be so
frustrated so thankfully it's just one
line super easy to add just make sure
you add it so lifecycle wise here we
have we're showing our notification when
we start playing will pause it when we
update it when we paused anytime we're
changing the state and then of course
when we stopped or destroy will want to
clear the notification now one thing you
might consider here is sometimes it
makes sense to actually keep your
notification around just a little bit
longer before you actually stopped in
case the user wants to restart say they
reach the end of their playlist so don't
consider it necessarily a hard
requirement to remove your notification
but in all cases you should consider
maybe a timeout kind of a system so
media playback is actually one of the
things that's
actually going to be a really good
candidate for foreground services
foreground services raise the priority
of your background service such that it
isn't killed in only the most extreme
memory conditions so this is great
because it's super noticeable when the
media playback app is killed in the
background because you know media
playback stops so foreground services
have a requirement that you have a
notification and thankfully we just
built a notification so it should be
fairly easy to get this actually started
as a foreground service now there's one
caveat though prior to lollipop if you
call start for stop foreground false you
actually can't swipe dismiss the
notification and this is actually a
really common case in media playback
apps because you don't necessarily need
to be a foreground service when you're
not playing audio right in theory in the
most memory hard areas you'll probably
not want to be a foreground service when
your plate when you're stopped playback
so how do I work around this bug we
fixed it in lollipop that doesn't help
people who are not min SDK 21 anyone
know one lucky here so meaty style kind
of built something for it cancel button
a simple X in the corner that allows
users even prior to lollipop to remove
your notification even though they can't
ever swipe it away so actually extremely
easy to add your call site show cancel
button true and then add the intent to
send stop playback now the nice part is
is because we fixed it in lollipop these
calls won't actually do anything on
lollipop and above they're just only for
backward compatibility reasons on
lollipop it above as soon as you hit
pause and you set your state to pause
and you stop being a foreground service
you can swipe away the notification
without a problem
so we've updated our notification now
we're going to start foreground stop
foreground false to keep the
notification around but not be a
foreground service and then stop
foreground true to remove our
notification when we've actually stops
entirely and actually our services this
is about everything right it's a lot but
we've actually handled all the things
that our service can handle there's just
one thing we still need to do build a UI
right like that's kind of a big deal for
most media playback about apps maybe if
you had like a single radio station that
would be really boring but could maybe
get away with it so we have to figure
out some way of connecting our service
to our UI and ideally we'd like to reuse
all of those callbacks Leon play on
pause on stop that we already have in
our service for hooking up our buttons
to it so we built one of those it's
called media controller compact and it's
actually the way of once you connect you
can actually get all of the current meta
data so you can update your UI to say
what's currently playing you can
actually get the playback state so
you'll know hey are we playing are we
paused or rebuffing so you'll be able to
update the UI based on those actions and
then there's also a transport controls
callback and here actually gives you
kind of that one to one so it has
methods like play pause skip to next
that directly correspond with the
callback we've registered in our media
session combat so you can very easily
hook up then your play button to
transport controls play and you're done
no additional communication steps you
need as soon as you have a media
controller compat it's one thing though
you actually need to get immediate
controller compat instance and to do
that we're actually going to use that
same session token that we added to our
notification we just somehow need to get
that from our service to our UI so
there's a really nice class that does
that too
it's like thought of everything it's
called Media Browser service and the
Media Browser and when you create a
media browser service rather than just a
service it actually gives you mechanisms
to connect to your service from your UI
and then retrieve the token as well as
get new api's which you guessed it
allows you to browse media on your
device so this may be able to easily
build out your UI based on say a list of
tracks or a list of albums and any other
kind of things you want there's actually
required for Android auto integration if
you think about Android auto you don't
have control over the UI itself because
of car safety but you do have control
over what audio tracks appear in your
media playback and that's all done
through Media Browser service it also
adds a browse action on Android wear
which if you scroll all the way over
from a playback action you'll see a
browse button you'll actually be able to
collect select the next track directly
from there so it's really simple to
actually use Media Browser service
instead of extending service you extend
Media Browser service and there was just
one method to do set session token' in
your oncreate this is what ties in that
session token' so that your media
browser service knows alright well what
is that token I need of course there are
the new methods on get root which is
kind of the root of your whole
application as well as onload children
on load item which you could expect
loads a list of tracks or a single track
and we actually have an example the
universal Android music player you amp
which goes through this entire flow and
has a lot more code it goes through
basically everything we've talked about
here today now one downside is that
Media Browser service is API 21 and
above so we're actually working on back
boarding it right now we have a version
that works it's going to be in the next
version support library but if you can't
wait there's a few things you can do in
the meantime because remember all we
need is just a token in are you
line so we could actually just use a
static method and called get session
token which then retrieves the token
right if you have your favorite event
bus application of choice there's
certainly very many ways of getting a
random item from one to the other it do
note that the session token is parcel
able so you can send it over broadcasts
or between processes without a problem
the other choice is to kind of build a
media browser service light basically do
your own binding to the service and then
actually just have the get token as part
of that bind or API so it's a little bit
more complicated to get through that but
we have a nice article about bound
services if you're interested in going
through that approach well and so that's
about everything this this is the slide
I could have just given to you this at
the beginning but I would have felt a
little anti-climactic but this is
actually everything that we need to get
our service to be doing literally
everything it possibly can to give the
best user experience for our users that
means playing well with audio playback
having controls everywhere possible
using notifications and using a
foreground service to make sure we're
not killed in the background as well as
doing Android wear and Android auto
integrations so that your media playback
works perfectly everywhere so if you
have any questions for me feel free to
reach out to me on Google+ or Twitter
happy to answer your questions thanks
again
love